hey guys is 15 and today you are
watching a virtual reality videos he can
work around you can look up you can look
down as we explore national Jet
Propulsion lab I'm so excited because
I've wanted to visit this place for so
long this is where they build the robots
they send up into solar system we're
going to be checking out first Mission
Control where they gather and they kind
of make sense of all of that information
of those robots in the world are sending
down it to us let's go take a look don't
forget guys this is virtual reality look
around have a peek see what you can see
you never know what you might see you
can see a lot of
[Music]
hi Tracy hey there thanks so much for
joining us today
absolutely so what exactly do you do
here like what is your full title
I am the Juno deputy chief engineer and
what that job means right now that we're
enough is that when things go wrong with
a spacecraft I help work with the team
to figure out how to resolve it we're
here in Mission Control so you take a
look like a little quick tour like what
happens here absolutely so this room you
can kind of think of it as the center of
the universe because this is a place
where all the spacecraft that are out
passing over to the moon that are using
the Deep Space Network to send their
data back their data comes to those
networks
that's adds a Madrid Goldstone Canberra
it all comes through to this room where
people like the data control or the
operations chief make sure there's
nothing wrong with that data flow and
it's getting out to the operators of the
mission and science teams so they can do
everything they need to do so you've
been working on Juno and you're so
currently on that project so what's that
kind of been like for you from start to
not quite finished but currently where
it is now it's been pretty amazing I
joined the Dino team in 2009 about two
years before launch getting through all
the things we needed to do to prepare
the spacecraft to go on this long
journey and get super dirt and do stuff
it launched in August 2011 pick a
five-year cruise figured out there we
had plenty of things to do when you
think that what right and plenty of
things that would not provide for us to
deal with and then we arrived on July
4th 2016
we have the Challenger furnco dock on
Delta B Roger Coleman Jonas Juneau
welcome Jupiter
so you know not only Jindal is going on
if you clearly have tons of other things
so what else can we look forward to hear
from you guys and that's coming years
yeah we have a few really major missions
that are in the works right now there is
the Mars 2020 which is the next Rover
going to Mars curiosity is still there
and working one of our na our Rovers is
still working but we're looking to put a
new suite of instruments and go explore
our new spot on Mars with that mission
in 2020 there's also the Europa mission
which is really awesome because it's
doing their expressly to study the moon
of Jupiter which they think has liquid
water under a shell of ice one of the
more in my opinion I'm not a scientist
in a connection between one of the
possibly more likely places for there to
be life in our solar system so exciting
to see are things you guys are doing so
congratulations on the amazing mission
and all of your future mission thank you
I appreciate it after coming to thank
you there's one thing that I've noticed
here is they have peanuts everywhere I
mean they're even right here on this
cardboard cut-out and I say hey it's
crazy how are you good are you thanks
for joining us oh yeah go for me so one
of the things that I've noticed what's
the route was up with it yes re-election
tradition here at JPL so in the 1960s we
were sending the first robotic
spacecraft to the moon we're trying to
understand what the moon would look like
at the scale humans were going to land
we have to figure out the terrain so we
sent these space covers basically
missiles with a camera on them they were
meant to cross into the moon but just
take pictures into a very last moment
here the problem one through six all
failed they blew up a rocket they missed
the moon entirely we have cameras that
didn't work so kind of a problem
Ranger seven though the sevens mission
and the trend finally worked and they
looked around the room we were trying to
figure out what was different between
Ranger seven of the previous six and
they saw peanuts we're in the room so
since then we've actually had peanuts
that all of our major events of
curiosity's launch and landing as you
know cheaper organization all these
times we have peanuts in the room you
know we like to say it's a tradition not
superstition yes of course about you
know well I'm not going to complain
cause there's really snacks everywhere
okay well thanks is great do you have a
couple of these in your house no but you
know this be great my office to pretend
that I'm working with them
thank you guys so much for watching and
a huge thank you to JPL for letting me
take this amazing tour and bring you
guys along with me for the ride I will
see you guys later hope you guys enjoy
the video make sure you go back and
watch again
never know what you might miss